what's up wisecrack jared here it's no
secret that daddy issues are to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe what HPV is to
a college campus everybody's got it
indeed paternal drama pops up constantly
in these films from Odin putting Thor
and timeout on earth to black panther
traveling to the ancestral plane to yell
at his dad to Peter quill confronting
his celestial egomaniac of a father
what's more many of the characters are
fathers themselves from ant-man to
Hawkeye and of course Big Daddy Thanos
but father conflicts are perhaps most
present and poignant when it comes to
Tony Stark
not only is he a literal father an end
game but he's always struggling with his
relationship with his own father and
acting as a surrogate father to Peter
Parker as seen in Avengers infinity war
and spider-man homecoming the nuances of
Marvel fatherhood have been covered in
videos by the take and just right so
definitely check those out but we think
Marvel's take on fatherhood is
undergoing a possible shift and that
this change occurred somewhere between
endgame and spider-man far from home
depictions of fatherhood are starting to
get a little more complicated and we
think it all has to do with the idea of
projection like literal projectors and
also emotional projection so welcome to
this wisecrack edition on fatherhood in
the MCU post endgame and of course
spoilers ahead for endgame and far from
home our guys let's do a quick recap of
far from home which sees Peter Parker
euro trippin and hoping to give that
Spidey suit a break so he can just be a
normal teen this plane is derailed when
very large very ugly monsters start
popping off all over Venice
Peter tries to fight them and runs into
Mysterio who seems like a nice enough
dude then the scroll version of Nick
Fury tracks Peter down to say that Tony
left behind a pair of uber high-tech
glasses that need to be gifted to the
next leader of the Avengers
Peter's like not it and goes back to
awkward flirting with MJ then he
realizes the right answer give the
glasses to his newest friend Mysterio
only turns out Mysterio is actually a
disgruntled former employee of Tony's
who made up a fake sob story about his
dead family and invented a projection
system that he uses to make everybody
think the world is under attack when
really it's just being blown to pieces
drone technology Peter stops him reclaim
the glasses and gets with MJ so that's
nice so how does spider-man far from
home perpetuate and evolve the theme of
fatherhood there are a few dynamics
worth mentioning most literally 1 Peter
is missing his father figure and 2
Mysterio lies about being a father who
lost his children then less literally
free the Avengers are without a leader
and people are looking to place the
responsibility on spider-man's shoulders
and for Mysterio is trying to fill
society's paternal void that Tony left
behind to understand this last point
more we're gonna have to dip into some
Sigmund Freud because sorry the dude is
still relevant in his book civilization
and its discontents Freud meditates on
among other things the origin of
religious feelings which he credits
entirely to our childhood longing for a
father figure the way he sees a
childhood as a state of inherent
helplessness in which we are at the
mercy of adults who parade us around in
ridiculous onesies Freud identifies
helplessness along with the resulting
longing for the father and his
protection as the source of all
religious feelings even wrote I cannot
think of any need in childhood as strong
as the need for a father's protection
which means he obviously never tried
pizza bagels as a result he notes that
we pretty much can't imagine God other
than in the figure of an enormous Lee
exalted father complete with a white
beard and a scowl because you didn't
clean your room ok so God equals death
but according to Freud there's more to a
father's role in your psyche and it has
to do with this theory of the developing
mind for Freud human brains developed
like this first you are pure in or the
base desires to eat scream and poop then
as you realize there are objects outside
of you like your teddy bear your spork
or your mom's Visa card you start to
develop an ego or the organizational
part of your brain that does stuff like
reason plan and decide to opt out of
Park horn but there's one thing left
that still has to develop your super-ego
the super-ego is according to Freud the
part of our brain that retains the
character of the Father that is it's the
part of us that internalizes our dad's
voice we do this because when we're tiny
our father seems all-knowing and
generally badass
of course we eventually grow up and
realize that our dads make mistakes too
and sometimes randomly send their rabbi
hate mail or is it just me anyway we'll
often turn to religion as we seek to
replace our flesh-and-blood father with
a sort of cosmic father that still
retains all the dope qualities of our
real dad besides God we can also project
our super-ego onto any group of people
or individual leader whether of the
state of a political party or of a
superhero team which brings us back to
Marvel now we see fan oohs taking it
upon himself to fulfill the role Freud
describes as paternal and infinity war
and end game dudes followers are
literally called the children of Thanos
and ebony ma actually says that everyone
is his child even in death or even in
death you have become children what's
more we see him take a break from
conquering a planet in order to adopt
Gamora as a surrogate daughter but most
starkly Thanos takes up the mantle of
celestial father when he makes a
decision on behalf of the whole effing
universe that half of life should be
destroyed because he knows best his life
is left unchecked life who ceased to
exist
it needs don't know that I'm the only
one who knows that here we see fan OHS
choosing to fulfill the father role or
the super-ego for a universe he
genuinely thinks needs him true Thanos
the series shows us a majorly flawed but
powerful paternal God figure what's more
it furthers a theme omnipresent in the
series children paying for the sins of
their fathers many Marvel heroes are
essentially sons of villains are at
least coping with their father's
failures the chala has to deal with the
fallout of his father's mistakes
star-lord has to stop his dad from
taking over the universe Iron Man has to
grow up to be better than his dad and
Thor has to confront his dad's seedy
history of conquest Thanos is the
logical conclusion to this motif he's
destroying half of humanity and leaving
his children behind to pick up the
pieces
then there's Tony Stark who as we
previously noted had an interesting
father-son relationship with both his
own father and surrogate son Peter
Parker and indeed with the entire
Avengers of whom he was largely
considered to be the leader
actually acts as sort of shadow to
Thanos in Civil War he seeks to grant
the government power over the Avengers
through the sokovia accords an endgame
he regrets not building a suit of armor
around the world to save everyone from
Thanos what we needed was a pseudo armor
around the world
remember that eventually he even
sacrifices himself for all of humanity
a move that's pretty damn protective all
these acts imply that he knows what's
best for Humanity though he does it in a
way that is far more benevolent than the
overbearing destruction happy father
figure that is Thanos Tony's paternalism
is even made literal an end game when he
actually has a daughter but now Tony is
dead and Phase three of the franchise
has ended are we seeing a subsequent
shift in the way the theme of fatherhood
manifests Tony's death leaves the
Avengers and the world at large
reeling without a father figure to unite
them unquestionably there seems to be a
real need for this father figure
evidenced by everyone's clear desire to
see Tony replaced and fast people start
by harassing spider-man who as Tony's
mentee and not obviously a 16 year old
seems like the logical replacement the
central plotline of this film what to do
with those damn glasses is really about
finding the next father figure for the
Avengers without a father figure to look
to Peter seems lost and directionless
hence his relief at discovering Mysterio
with whom he immediately forms a close
connection he and Mysterio develop a
sort of father-son relationship growing
out at bars and fighting fake elementals
together Mysterio even offers Peter
advice and not a jerk for wanting a
normal life kid this relationship is
unmistakably parental and consistent
with Peter's enduring urge to be
protected by a father figure if it seems
like Mysterio is starting to replace
Tony as Peters metaphorical that things
are about to get a lot more literal
indeed because of his trust in and
genuine affection for Mysterio Peter
decides that he should be the new head
of the Avengers and thereby assumed both
roles Tony left unfulfilled
but Peter quickly realizes he made an
oopsie because Mysterio turns out to be
a grade-a scumbag who is actually
manipulating high-tech projections to
make people think that they're under
attack while simultaneously blowing
their cities to smithereens via an army
of drones
part of his elaborate scheme includes
telling a lie about being a father
and losing his entire family to these
elementals on a different version of
Earth the strongest of them all the one
that destroyed my earth it's the one
that took my family his heroism like the
supposed protection of your father is
literally an illusion Peter is
appropriately bummed you lied to me
I trusted you that doesn't mean that
Mysterio was acting out of some random
destructive urge or the desire to own a
cool pair of specs
he's more interesting than that we get
some insight into what's going on
beneath that fishbowl when Mysterio
tries to kill Peter I created with Syrio
to give them basically Mysterio
recognizes that Tony functioned as a
kind of super-ego for the world with
Tony gone he sees a way to fill that
void specifically by creating a
make-believe threat and then defeating
said threat through elaborate green
smoke throwing he made those crazy-ass
projections because he wanted to give
the people someone to project their
fears and hopes and beliefs onto he
wanted to be their daddy sorry couldn't
resist
so is Mysterio right does the world need
a super-ego to look up to or is the film
saying that this kind of figure is
largely illusory to begin with indeed
illusion and deception are one of the
primary themes of the film from happy
pretending not to date and may 2mj
pretending that she's only interested in
Peter because she thinks he's spider-man
even Peter is not immune to illusions
donning a fake spider-man suit so that
his classmates don't figure him out then
obviously there's Mysterio who traffics
and illusions inventing is half-baked
superhero status from scratch oh and
also all the literal allusions this
overarching theme and particularly the
way it interacts with fatherhood makes
us think that there may be a shift in
the way the MCU will approach fatherhood
as it enters phase four because perhaps
there's one more illusion to consider
Tony Stark's legacy indeed Tony has
never been more heroic than in death has
first exemplified in this dramatically
corny PowerPoint presentation but the
film complicates this notion when it
reveals that all of the bad guys are
former
employees who found Tony evil
incompetent or condescending the man who
brought us all together our former boss
Tony Stark the Jester King literally
wrapped in wealth and technology that he
was unfit to wield there are other
issues with Tony's legacy from the
villains he made out of vulture and
Ultron to his legacy as an arms dealer
to him siding with the government in
civil war perhaps happy puts at best
nobody can live up to Tony not even Tony
emphasizing the extent to which the myth
is often greater than the man on top of
that by having Peter's new father figure
turn out to be a big old fake Marvel
calls into question a central premise of
the film it asks if what the world
really needs is a new Tony Stark
particularly if the real Tony had his
fair share of flaws so what's the
world's highest grossing franchise to do
Marvel could repeat these similar themes
and tropes of previous films or it could
pivot towards entirely new disposition
towards father figures in one important
scene near the end of the film we see
signs that the franchise could go either
way
Peter's gearing up for his final battle
with Mysterio
and happy gives him that look the
subtext being Wow he's reminding me of
Tony so is Peter going to be just like
Tony is he going to inherit the same
complexities of father-son relationships
we've seen thus far in the MCU or is
this an indication of progress that he
as well as the rest of the Marvel Canon
will move past the myth of the father as
our collective super-ego one quick note
and it wouldn't be wise crack if we
didn't get a little meta so indulge us
we think it's worth mentioning there's
actually another layer to this drama
specifically having to do with the
recently resolved fight Sony and Marvel
had over the IP rights to spider-man
with the threat of Sony permanently
stealing spider-man from the Avengers
fans felt betrayed almost like they were
losing their superhero leader and they
didn't know how to orient themselves to
that version of reality sound familiar
on some level spider-man's own crisis
was also just lived out amongst his
loyal fans so as you can see there's
potentially a lot going on when Peter
Dawn's those glasses and it poses some
major questions about the future of the
franchise so what do you guys think
Peter rise and become the teen dad that
the Avengers so badly want or will
Marvel evolve past its depiction of
paternal figures as the ultimate
protectors let us know which thing in
the comments and make sure you hit that
subscribe button thanks to all our
patrons and before you go want to make
sure you head to wix.com slash wisecrack
for all your website needs if you're a
freelancer just starting out in the real
world be sure to put your best foot
forward with an awesome portfolio or if
you're a business looking for some more
foot traffic create a site and optimize
it so locals will find you create your
own website at wix.com slash wisecrack
and as always thanks for watching guys
peace
[Music]
you